CARLSON TONIGHT, THE CONTRAST
BETWEEN EL PASO, TEXAS AND
WHEREAS MEXICO HAS BEEN ONE OF
THE GREAT ADVERTISEMENTS FOR
AMERICA AND FOR THE AMERICAN WAY
.
THEY ARE LITERALLY RIGHT NEXT T
EACH OTHER.
FROM DOWNTOWN EL PASO YOU CAN
SEE DOWNTOWN OR IS.
MOST PEOPLE IN EL PASO HAD
RELATIVES IN MEXICO.
THE DIFFERENCE IS ONE CITY IS
AMERICAN AND ONE IS NOT.
EL PASO HAS BEEN TRANQUIL, AND
ORDERLY AND REALLY NICE.
IN 2010, OR IS REPORTED MORE
THAN 3,000 IN EL PASO.
HOURS, AND ON THE OTHER SIDE
THAT THIRD WORLD.
THIS EXCESSIVE EL PASO SAID
EVERYTHING IS THE SUPERIORITY O
THE AMERICAN SYSTEM IN THE
CULTURE.
BUT TWO YEARS AGO JOE BIDEN SET
OUT TO CHANGE THAT.
IT WAS A DEFENSE AGAINST EQUITY
THEY WERE TWO DIFFERENT, BUT
INSTEAD OF FIXING OR IS, HE
DECIDED TO DESTROY IT WHEREAS
AND MAKE IT MUCH MORE LIKE WHER
IS.
THEY OPEN THE BORDER TO THE
WORLD, NO WHERE WAS HIT HARD BY
THAT DECISION THEN EL PASO,
TEXAS.
EL PASO HAS RISEN BY MORE THAN
280 PERCENT, HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF FOREIGN NATIONALS
STREAMING INCOME AT JOBLESS,
PENNILESS, ANONYMOUS.
WHAT HAPPENED NEXT?
YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENED NEXT.
THE MOST PREDICTABLE DISASTER
AND THE WORLD.
CRIME SKYROCKETED, SOCIAL
COHESION COLLAPSED.
TEST SCORES IN LOCAL SCHOOLS
PLUMMETED AND THE CITY BEGAN TO
FALL APART.
PEOPLE WHO GREW UP IN EL PASO
STARTED TO LEAVE IN LARGE
NUMBERS.
THIS IS WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE RIGH
NOW.
>> A CHILLY NIGHT, THESE
MIGRANTS ARE HOMELESS, CAMPING
ON THE STREETS REPAIR FOR A
NIGHT OF BITTER COLD AFTER THEY
WERE RELEASED FROM CUSTODY.
THE MIGRANT SURGE OVERWHELMING
LOCAL SHELTERS IS THIS AN
PRECEDENT CRIME SCENE IS HEADED
FOR WITH TITLE 40 TO SET TO DRO
NEXT WEEK.
THERE IS NO REPEAT PROVED COMING
.
AS NEW FOX NEWS VIDEO, SHOWS
OVER 1,000 MIGRANTS CAMPED AT
THE BORDER WHILE IN EL PASO LAS
NIGHT WAITING TO BE LET IN FOR
PROCESSING AFTER THEY CROSSED
THE RIO GRANDE ILLEGALLY.
THE EL PASO SECTOR HAS ALREADY
SEEN OVER 139,000 MIGRANTS
ENCOUNTER SINCE OCTOBER 1ST.
THAT'S ENOUGH TO FELL OUT THE
STADIUM TWICE, AND.
>> IMAGINE IF THAT WAS YOUR
SAFETY.
WHERE YOU WORK IN REACH HER
FAMILY SED THAT YOU BUILT.
AND THEN WEDNESDAY, THAT MEDIA
IGNORES A, NOBODY COVER SEPARAT
MOST AMERICANS HAVE NO IDEA THE
CITY HAS BEEN DESTROYED?
IT'S NOT JUST DOWNTOWN AND IT'S
NOT JUST THE AIRPORT, THE WINDO
INTO A PASO AND CASE YOU HAVE
FLOWN THERE, PEOPLE SEEM TO BE
CAMPING ON THE FLOOR OF THE
PLACE.
IT LOOKS LIKE THE TRAIN STATION
IN CALCUTTA.
AT LEAST THEY HAD THE WORD TO
BRING LIMIT ON.
THIS COUSINS FROM THE COURT OF
RUBBLE NEWS.
>> I JUST LANDED IN EL PASO,
TEXAS, AND HERE AT THE EL PASO
AIRPORT IS AN INFLUX OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS SLEEPING ON THE
AIRPORT FLOORS.
TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT IS HAPPENIN
HERE IN THE AIRPORTS.
>> REAL?
PERU.
[FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
>> COLUMBIA.
>> THAT IS THE AIRPORT.
THEY'RE NOT WAITING FOR FLIGHTS
THEY ARE LIVING THERE.
THEY ARE NOT FROM MEXICO OR EVE
EL SALVADOR OR GUATEMALA.
THEY ARE FROM COLUMBIA, PERU,
THE DOMINICAN REPUBLIC, THESE
ARE COUNTRIES THOUSANDS OF MILE
AWAY, TO WHICH WE OWE NOTHING.
THERE IS NO REASON FOR THIS.
THERE ARE 7 MILLION AMERICAN OF
WORKING AGE THAT ARE NOT WORKING
, THEY'RE ON THE INTERNET
ALL DAY, THEY HAVE NOTHING TO DO
.
THE MAYOR OF EL PASO ASKED FOR
THEY DID DECLARE A STATE OF
EMERGENCY.
>> IT WAS TIME TO CALL A STATE
OF EMERGENCY.
AND THE REASON WE ARE DOING IT
IS BECAUSE I SAID FROM THE
BEGINNING THAT I WOULD CALL IT
WHEN I FELT THAT EITHER OUR
ASYLUM-SEEKERS OR OUR COMMUNITY
WAS NOT SAFE.
I BELIEVE TODAY THAT OUR
ASYLUM-SEEKERS AREN'T SAFE AS W
HAVE HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS ON
THE STREETS.
EL PASO WASN'T LIKE THIS A FEW
YEARS AGO.
ASK ANYBODY WHO WENT THERE, THE
QUESTION IS, WHY ISN'T THE STAT
OF TEXAS DROPPING THIS?
WHERE IS THE TEXAS NATIONAL
GUARD.
A FEW YEARS AGO GREG ABBOTT WAS
RUNNING FOR TEXAS AND WAS
WILLING TO SAY ANYTHING TO GET
REELECTED.
HE SAID HE DEPLOYED 10,000
TROOPS TO THE BORDER, HE HAS
SINCE, HE'S REVISED IT TO 5,000
TROOPS AND MANY CAME UP WITH
ANOTHER SOLUTION JUST BLESSED
THOUSANDS OF MIGRANTS TO OTHER
STATES, WHICH IS KIND OF FUNNY
IT MAKES CABLE NEWS SEGMENT, BU
IT STILL OUR COUNTRY, ISN'T IT?
AND NONE OF THESE PEOPLE ARE
EVER LEAVING.
THIS IS AN INVASION OF OUR
COUNTRY.
WE DON'T HAVE A BORDER.
GRAY CAPITAL COULD STOP IT, BUT
HE ISN'T.
WHY ISN'T THE TEXAS NATIONAL
GUARD STOPPING THIS?
WEEK WOULD LOVE FOR GREG ABBOTT
TO COME ON AND TELL US, BUT
BECAUSE TEXAS IS IN SECURING TH
BORDER, THE REST OF THE COUNTRY
IS OVERRUN WITH PEOPLE FROM
OTHER COUNTRIES HIS IDENTITY WE
DON'T KNOW, THIS IS WHAT DENVER
COLORADO A LONG WAY FROM THE
BORDER LOOKS LIKE NOW.
>> WITH SEVERAL SHELTERS ALREAD
AT CAPACITY, WHERE IT MICHAEL
HANCOCK SAID MORE ARE NEEDED TO
HOUSE MIGRANTS MORE THAN 900
HAVE ARRIVED IN DENVER IN THE
PAST SEVERAL MONTHS WITH MORE
COMING EVERY DAY.
>> LET ME BE FRANK.
THIS INFLUX OF MIGRANTS AND THE
UNANTICIPATED ARRIVAL.
THIS HAS PUT AN IMMENSE TAINT
STRAIN ON CITY RESOURCES TO THE
LEVEL WHERE WE ARE ON THE VERGE
OF REACHING A BREAKING POINT.
THAT IS IN DENVER, AGAIN, A LON
WAY FROM THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
THIS IS THE BIGGEST STORY IN
RECENT AMERICAN HISTORY, BUT
TOTAL CHANGE IN THE AMERICAN
POPULATION, MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF NEW
PEOPLE.
THE COUNTRY WILL NEVER BE WHAT
IT WAS FIVE YEARS AGO.
EVEN IF YOU ARE FOR THIS, YOU
WOULD ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THIS IS
BIG DEAL AND IT'S COMPLETELY
IGNORED BY THE MEDIA EXCEPT WHE
THEY ARE FORCED TO RESPOND AND
THEY TELL YOU TO SHUT UP.
ON ABC NEWS SOMEONE CALLED
MARTHA ARGUED IT'S ACTUALLY
PEOPLE AGAINST IMMIGRATION WHO
OUR TO BLAME FOR THE IMMIGRATIO
CRISIS BECAUSE THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT IT AND THEREFORE
ADVERTISING IT TO THE REST OF
THE WORLD.
>> YOU TALK ABOUT THE BOARD
WHILE, YOU TALK ABOUT OPEN
BORDERS, I DON'T THINK I'VE EVE
HEARD PRESIDENT BY DIDN'T SAY W
HAVE AN OPEN BORDER COME ON OVER
, THE PEOPLE I'VE HEARD SAY
IT'S ARE YOU, OUR FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP, RHONDA SANTOS,
THAT MESSAGE REVERBERATES IN
MEXICO AND BEYOND.
SO THEY DO GET THAT MESSAGE THA
IT IS IN OPEN BORDER AND
SMUGGLERS USE ALL THOSE KINDS O
STATEMENTS.
>> I DO FERVENTLY WISH THE
HAITIANS WOULD MOVE TO HER
NEIGHBORHOOD TONIGHT.
MAY BE SHE WOULD DIFFERENT
COVERAGE.
UNTIL THEN, THE DEMOCRATIC PART
IS PROBABLY GOING TO CONTINUE
LYING.
REALLY ONLY RACISTS AND CRAZED
CONSPIRACY NUTS CARE ABOUT THE
BORDER.
>> YOU KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF
FOLKS AND THE MIDDLE THAT AREN'
VERY EMPATHETIC TO WHAT'S
HAPPENING AT THE BORDER.
HOW DO YOU CHANGE THE TONE TO
THAT CONVERSATION AND GET THEM
TO ACCEPT THE COMPROMISE.
>> I THINK THEY WILL.
I THINK MY VOTERS ARE REASONABLE
.
WE ARE ALL SLIGHTLY LEAN
REPUBLICAN STATE NOW.
I DON'T HEAR A LOT ABOUT
IMMIGRATION FROM VOTERS EXCEPT
PEOPLE ON THE FAR RIGHT AT
ALWAYS ONE TO GAIN POLITICAL
ADVANTAGE BY TALKING ABOUT A.
>> Tucker: THAT IS AMAZING.
A GUY THAT CARES ABOUT THE
LITTLE GUY IN DISPLACED FACTORY
WORKERS IN THOSE 7 MILLION
WORKING THAT ARE NOT WORKING,
THEY ARE PLAYING VIDEO GAMES.
HE WAS ELECTED BECAUSE HE
CLAIMED TO CARE ABOUT THEM.
IN FACT IT WASN'T THAT LONG AGO
THAT HE WAS AT THE BORDER
DECLARING A HUMANITARIAN CRISIS
BECAUSE PEOPLE WERE LIVING IN
CAGES, NOW THAT SAME MAN SAYS
YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO TALK ABOU
ANYTHING THAT'S HAPPENING AT TH
BORDER, PEOPLE CAMPING ON
STREETS OR AT THE AIRPORTS, YOU
ALSO CAN'T TALK ABOUT CONDITION
INSIDE MIGRANT DETENTION CENTER
ANYMORE BECAUSE THEY HAVE A
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENT.
TONY GONZALEZ JUST WENT TO AND
SHOT THE FOOTAGE WE ARE SEEN ON
YOUR SCREEN OUT THAT'S A
DETENTION CENTER IN EL PASO
INTENDED TO HOLD ABOUT 1,000
PEOPLE THERE ARE NOW MORE THAN
4,000 INSIDE OF